now the prime minister's former advisor
dominic cummings has published a
whatsapp message that apparently shows
boris johnson describing the health
secretary matt hancock as
hopeless in the screenshot published by
mr cummings on social media
he messages the prime minister about the
united states increasing testing
capacity
and criticizes mr hancock's response
boris johnson responds
totally expletive hopeless he was asked
about it as he left downing street this
morning
did you really think matt hancock was
useless sir
why didn't you suck him
sounds like john craig's dulcet tones he
didn't respond he was
asked again about his apparent
description of matt hancock during prime
minister's questions
as we enter the chamber we see what is
reported to be
whatsapp communication between the prime
minister and dominic cummings and
perhaps the prime minister
will clarify whether or not these are
genuine and whether derogatory comments
are they
expressed on its health secretary are
valid or not
mr speaker this morning the details of
the disastrous trade deal with australia
are slowly seeping out mr speaker this
is a
great deal for the uk it's a great deal
for
scotland uh it's a great deal for
scottish whiskey
uh well he avoided the question there as
well let's bring in skies deputy
political editor sam
coates sam what do we know about these
whatsapp exchanges dominic cummings
published them in a blog he says that
they are genuine
what is number 10 saying about them 7
600 word blog published minutes before
prime minister's questions kirsten
didn't manage to ask anything
about them in the exchanges in blackford
did you saw
the prime minister effectively
sidestepping the key question
which is whether or not it's genuine no
word or response from number 10
yet but what's going on is that dominic
cummings is essentially trying to
challenge
matt hancock and his evidence this
blog goes extensively through various
things and makes various claims about
what matt hancock did and didn't do and
did and didn't say
over the period particularly at the
height of the start of the pandemic
in march last year but leaving aside
common
cummings is extensively argued comments
what is fascinating is the pictures he
has taken
apparently of screenshot of
conversations
between himself and the prime minister
there are three
uh that relate to matt hancock one from
the 27th of march
in which as you say he uh was asked
about uh dominic cummings was
talking about uh the testing regime and
the prime minister replied
totally expletive hopeless and then
uh later it would appear on the same day
he was asked about
ventilators and the price of equipment
and he says uh it's hancock he has been
useless
uh and uh in a third message
a month later uh he uh appears to
suggest that he considered
taking hancock off and putting michael
gove in now it's not quite clear
whether he's referring to taking matt
hancock out of his job as health
secretary or just removing
responsibility for ppe dominic cummings
comes back and says
well the department that michael gove is
running isn't going terribly well either
uh and so uh there appears to be no
resolution there matt hancock still in
his job today dominic cummings isn't
because he left
in november what is the significance of
all of this
well i suspect that nobody if they stop
and think about it will be that surprise
that the height of the pandemic
where you are dealing with a one in a
hundred year event
things can get quite techy uh even at
the heart of downing street
and that many people might have
responded in similar ways
but it does raise a question about the
categorical assurances
categorical exchanges that matt hancock
and uh boris johnson were always on the
same page the dinars
uh that boris johnson ever had any
concerns about matt hancock
and that he ever thought about moving
him from his job or changing
his role so those are the issues to
focus on if you just take the text
messages
alone between the prime minister and
boris johnson and a lot more to argue
about
uh if you take what what else dominic
cummings has written at face value